bueno quiero empezar haciéndoles una
pregunta
cuántos de ustedes han tenido que llenar
un formulario en el internet en el cual
han tenido que ingresar unas letras
distorsionadas así como estas
cuantos odian hacer eso
excelente bueno eso lo inventé yo
eso se llama un captcha y la razón por
la que está ahí es para asegurarse de
que la entidad llenando el formulario
realmente es un humano y no una
computadora o un programa de una
computadora que fue escrito para llenar
ese formulario millones de millones de
veces la razón por la que esta función
es porque los humanos pueden leer estos
caracteres distorsionados pero las
computadoras simplemente no lo pueden
hacer aún por ejemplo
cuando están comprando boletos en el
internet para algún concierto la razón
por la que tienen que ingresar esos esas
letras es para asegurarse de que los
revendedores de boletos no puedan
comprar no puedan hacer un programa que
compre todos los boletos dos a la vez
ahora estos son usados por todo el
internet ya que son usados tantas veces
muchas veces la secuencia exacta de
caracteres o de letras escogidas al azar
es un poco desafortunada por ejemplo
esto viene de yahoo
las letras escogidas totalmente al azar
en este caso fueron w
y t que en inglés es una palabra weight
que significa esperar pero lo mejor es
hablar de 20 minutos después el imeo que
recibió yahoo de este usuario
eso por supuesto no es tan malo como lo
que le pasó a esta pobre persona
bueno les puedo contar historias
divertidas de causas por horas pero como
no puedo hacer eso les quiero contar
acerca de otro proyecto que hicimos
después de este proyecto es como la
evolución de los cafés es un proyecto y
se llama recaptcha que es un proyecto
que empezamos como un proyecto en la
universidad después lo convertimos en
una compañía estado y después google
compró esa compañía así que por los
próximos cinco minutos todo lo que les
voy a decir es propiedad de google
hasta que no lo repitan
bueno esto este proyecto empezó con los
siguientes resulta ser que alrededor de
200 millones de copias son ingresadas
cada día ahora cuando me enteré de eso
yo estaba muy orgulloso de mí mismo y yo
pensé miren el impacto que mi trabajo ha
tenido pero después me empecé a sentir
mal no solo son odiosos sino además cada
vez que alguien ingresa un captcha
realmente pierden alrededor de 10
segundos de su tiempo y si multiplicamos
10 segundos por 200 millones llegamos a
que toda la humanidad está perdiendo
alrededor de 500 mil horas diarias
ingresando capas en el internet
entonces me empecé a sentir mal
y me puse a pensar será que existe
alguna manera cómo podemos utilizar este
esfuerzo para el bien de la humanidad la
razón por la que me puse a pensar en
esto es porque durante esos 10 segundos
que alguien está ingresando un captcha
su cerebro está haciendo algo increíble
su cerebro está haciendo algo que las
computadoras aún no pueden hacer
entonces será que podemos hacer que
hagan algo que sea beneficioso para la
humanidad otra manera de ponerlos era
que existe algún problema gigantesco que
aún no podemos lograr que las
computadoras resuelvan pero que podemos
dividir en pedacitos chiquitos tales que
cada vez que alguien resuelve un captcha
resuelve un pedacito de ese problema y
resulta ser que sí y eso es lo que
estamos haciendo ahora o sea que hoy en
día si alguien ingresa un captcha lo que
tal vez no saben es que no solo están
demostrando que son humanos sino además
nos están ayudando a digitalizar libros
deben explicarles cómo funciona eso hay
varios proyectos tratando de digitalizar
todos los libros que han sido escritos
que google tiene uno
amazon tiene otro con el quinto la
manera que eso funcione es que agarran
un libro una de esas cosas físicas las
han visto verdad esas cosas allá afuera
agarran un libro y lo escanean por
escanear un libro en lo que consiste
consiste en tomarle una foto digital a
cada página del libro es lo que es
escanear un libro le toma una foto
digital a cada página del libro el
próximo paso en ese proceso es que la
computadora tiene que descifrar todas
las palabras que están en esa foto es
una foto con palabras para computar
tiene que descifrar todas esas palabras
el problema es que para los libros que
fueron escritos hace ya varios años la
computadora no puede descifrar muchas de
esas palabras porque la tinta ya se
gastó las páginas ya se tornaron
amarillas entonces ya la palabra seguir
un poquito diferente y la computadora no
la puede descifrar
para libros que fueron escritos hace más
de 50 años la computadora no puede
cifrar alredor de 30% de las palabras
entonces lo que estamos haciendo ahora
es que estamos agarrando todas las
palabras que la computadora no puede
descifrar y estamos haciendo que alguien
las descifra para nosotros en el
internet mientras bien algún captcha o
sea que la próxima vez tiene un captcha
o sea que la próxima tiene un captcha
esas palabras que están ingresando son
palabras que vienen directamente de
libros que han sido digitalizados y que
la computadora no pudo reconocer ahora
la razón por la que ahora tenemos dos
palabras en vez de una antes era sólo
una palabra ahora son dos la razón es
que ahora necesitamos dos palabras para
poder verificar si la respuesta está
correcta porque una de las palabras es
una palabra para la cual el sistema ya
sabe la solución y la otra palabra es
una palabra que el sistema acaba de
agarrar de un libro no sabe qué es
se le va enseñar algún usuario y lo que
vamos a hacer es que le vamos a decir al
usuario por favor ingrese ambas y no le
vamos a decir cuál es cuál y si ingresa
en la respuesta correcta para la cual el
sistema ya sabe la respuesta asumimos
que es un humano y además obtenemos un
poco de confianza que ingresaron la otra
correctamente y si repetimos este
proceso con 10 diferentes personas con
la nueva palabra y todos ingresan la
misma cosa con la nueva palabra
obtenemos mucha seguridad de esta nueva
palabra está correctamente digitalizada
es la manera en que funciona ese sistema
y lo bueno es que ha sido muy exitoso
estamos digitalizando alrededor de 100
millones de palabras diarias lo cual es
el equivalente alrededor de 2 millones
de libros al año
que están siendo digitalizados una
palabra a la vez por gente escribiendo
cartas en el internet ahora ya que
estamos haciendo tantas pares de
palabras ahora también pueden pasar
cosas interesantes o divertidas eso es
especialmente cierto porque ahora
estamos enseñando dos palabras en inglés
una a la par de la otra escogidas al
azar entonces eso puede llevar a cosas
divertidas que pasen por ejemplo
enseñamos esta palabra que solo es en
español de la palabra cristianos no no
tiene nada de malo pero si la ponemos
con otra palabra escogida totalmente al
azar pueden pasar cosas malas por
ejemplo enseñamos esto
es un poco divertido pero es aún peor
porque resulta ser hay millones de
sitios ellos dan captas en el internet
resulta ser que donde enseñamos a este
caption especial es un sitio que se
llama la embajada del reino de dios
aquí hay otro muy malo un político en
eeuu john edwards puntocom
y bueno insultamos la gente todos los
días con esto pero no solo son insultos
también muchas veces solo son cosas
interesantes que pueden pasar y eso ha
dado auge a una nueva moda en el
internet en la cual han participado
miles de miles de personas que se llama
captcha art o arte de captchas la idea
estamos la siguiente imagínense que
están
navegando el internet y de repente miran
un captcha que les parece interesante
como este
lo que se supone que tiene que hacer es
tomar una captura de pantalla después
tienen que ingresar el captcha porque
así nos ayudan a digitalizar libros por
favor
y después lo que se supone que tienen
que hacer es dibujar algo basado en este
caso y ponerlo con el captcha así como
esto
ese es un ejemplo de arte de captura en
miles de miles de miles de esas hay unos
como este interesantes hay otros como
éste que son más tiernos
y hay otros como éste que son mucho más
divertidos
este es mi este es mi número favorito
acerca de este proyecto 900 millones ese
es el número total de personas distintas
que nos han ayudado a digitalizar al
menos una palabra de algún libro a
través de capas un poco más del 10% a la
humanidad nos ha ayudado a digitalizar
libros ahora son números como este los
que motivan mi trabajo y en particular
la pregunta que me motiva a mí es la
siguiente si miramos todos los proyectos
más grandes de la historia de la
humanidad todos esos megaproyectos que
ha hecho la humanidad como por ejemplo
las pirámides de egipto
el canal de panamá o poner un hombre en
la luna algo curiosa acerca a todos
estos megaproyectos es que todos fueron
hechos con alrededor del mismo número de
personas todos fueron hechos con
alrededor de 100 mil personas y nos
podemos preguntar por qué es que todos
usaron alrededor del mismo número
personas y la razón es porque antes del
internet coordinar a más de 100 mil
personas era imposible pero ahora con el
internet les acabo enseñar un proyecto
donde hemos coordinado a 900 millones de
personas entonces la pregunta que me
motiva a mí es si podemos poner a un
hombre en la luna con 100.000 personas
qué podemos hacer con 100 millones de
personas y basado en esta pregunta hemos
trabajado en varios proyectos no les voy
a decir todos los que hemos hecho pero
les quiero contar acerca de uno que
estamos trabajando ahorita que llevamos
alrededor de dos años trabajando en este
proyecto y lo vamos a lanzar en
alrededor de 30 días porque ya estamos a
punto de lanzarlo es un proyecto que se
llama duolingo y este proyecto empezó
con la siguiente pregunta que pregunté
la siguiente cómo podemos hacer que 100
millones de personas traduzca en el
internet
todos los mayores idiomas de gratis
hay varias cosas que decir acerca de
esta pregunta la primera es traducir en
internet como todos sabemos el internet
está partido en varios idiomas una gran
fracción está en inglés y si alguien no
sabe inglés y no puede accesar lo pero
hay fracciones en otros idiomas y si
alguien no sabe esos idiomas no lo
podemos accesar yo quisiera traducir
todo el internet a todos los mayores
idiomas es lo que yo quisiera hacer
ahora si es lo que quiero hacer
mucha gente me podría decir por qué no
usamos computadoras para hacerlo
últimamente las computadoras están
traduciendo algunas oraciones aquí hay
agua pero como todos sabemos las
computadoras simplemente no son muy
buenas para traducir y no van a hacer
conocemos no van a ser muy buenas por
los próximos 20 ó 30 años déjenme
enseñarles solo un ejemplo que puede
pasar cuando traducimos algo con
computadoras esto es un ejemplo que
encontramos en un foro en internet
acerca de pero que es un foro de para
preguntas de programación o sea esta es
una pregunta programación que fue
traducida del japonés al inglés y diario
la traduce al español pero pero mi
traducción es buena la otra es la que es
mala
entonces solo lo voy a dejar que lean
esto al principio sólo está pidiendo
perdón por el hecho que es una
traducción por cierto esto fue hecho con
el mejor programa de traducción de
japonés inglés
recuerden esto se supone que es una
pregunta acerca de programación
aquí viene el preámbulo de la pregunta
después viene la primera parte de la
pregunta
después viene mi parte favorita la
y después viene mi parte favorita de
todo el mensaje
las computadoras no son muy buenas así
que necesitamos humanos entonces lo que
yo quiero hacer es que si a millones de
personas
traduzca en el internet todos los
mayores idiomas y de gratis no no creo
que les pueda pagar yo a 100 millones de
personas entonces quiero que lo hagan de
gratis ahora sí eso es lo que quiero
hacer cuando empezamos a trabajar en
este proyecto nos dimos cuenta que
habían dos grandes obstáculos para poder
para lograr hacer esto el primero
es la falta de personas bilingües yo no
sé si existen 100 millones de personas
que usan el internet que son
suficientemente bilingües para ayudarnos
a traducir ese es un gran problema el
segundo problema es la falta de
motivación como vamos a hacer para
motivar a personas para que traduzcan de
gratis cómo vamos a hacer para eso
después de pensar en estos problemas por
por varios meses nos dimos cuenta que
había unas una manera resolver ambos
problemas con la misma solución nos
dimos cuenta que había una manera de
matar dos pájaros de un tiro
y la manera es transformar la traducción
de idiomas en algo que millones de
personas quieren hacer y que además
ayuda con el problema de falta de
personas bilingües y eso es el
aprendizaje de otros idiomas en razón de
hacer que millones de personas que
quieren aprender otros idiomas hoy en
día hay 1.2 billones de personas en el
mundo aprendiendo otro idioma
y no sólo es porque los están forzando a
hacerlo en el colegio en eeuu por
ejemplo hay más de 5 millones de
personas que han pagado más de 500
dólares por programas de computación
para aprender nuevos idiomas
entonces mucha gente quiera prender
nuevos idiomas entonces lo que hemos
estado trabajando lo que hemos estado
haciendo por los últimos dos años es un
nuevo sitio internet que se llama
duolingo que la idea condujo lingua es
que la gente puede aprender un nuevo
idioma 100% de gratis y al mismo tiempo
mientras aprenden están traduciendo el
internet
o se aprenden traduciendo es la manera
en que funciona y la manera en que
funciona más precisamente es que cuando
están empezando les vamos a dar
oraciones muy sencillas del internet y
si no saben alguna palabra les vamos a
decir qué significa esa palabra pero
vamos a traduzca esta oración y resulta
ser que la gente si lo puede hacer
aunque no sepan nada del idioma si les
explicamos que si no llega la palabra y
la van a traducir y después van a ver
como otras personas todos en la misma
oración y así van a ir aprendiendo cómo
se traduce y después que van usando el
sitio les vamos a ir dando oraciones más
y más complejas y así nos va a ir
ayudando a traducir así es como funciona
el sitio ahora
que ya terminamos de construirlo y lo
que estamos haciendo ahora es solo
probándolo y ya cuando empezamos a
trabajar en esto yo no pensé que fuera a
funcionar la verdad pero resulta ser que
si funciona y es increíble en primer
lugar la gente aprende idiomas en este
caso estamos probando con personas que
saben inglés aprendiendo español y con
personas que están español aprendiendo
inglés y resulta ser que las personas
aprenden el idioma muy bien lo aprenden
tan bien como cualquier otro método
computarizado de aprender idiomas
pero aún más increíble las traducciones
que nos están dando la gente a la hora
que están aprendiendo son muy buenas es
más son tan buenas como las traducciones
que nos dan traductores profesionales
ahora hay un truco que estamos usando
para esto y es que cada oración la
traduce en varias personas varios varios
estudiantes y escogemos la mejor pero
resulta ser que está mejor es tan buena
como la que nos da un traductor
profesional y entonces este esto es muy
bueno pero además de que no cada oración
la está traduciendo muchas personas otra
cosa que es buena es que cuando vueling
o podemos traducir realmente bastante
rápido
déjenme darle un estimado de qué tan
rápido podemos traducir si queremos
traducir todo wikipedia del inglés al
español
por supuesto wikipedia existe en el
español pero es mucho más pequeña que
inglés es alrededor del 20 por ciento
del tamaño de inglés si quisiéramos
traducir todo wikipedia del inglés al
español con tubo link o si tuviéramos
100.000 usuarios aprendiendo inglés con
link o podríamos hacerlo en 5 semanas y
si tuviéramos un millón de usuarios
podríamos hacerlo en 80 horas
y ya que todos mis proyectos hasta la
fecha han logrado obtener más de un
millón de personas esperamos que podamos
traducir todo el internet de gratis
no hemos lanzados gol y no gracias
solo quiero dejarlos no hemos lanzado
duolingo pero lo vamos a hacer como en
30 días se van a dúo link o puntocom
pueden los vamos a dejar entrar al beta
privado en alrededor de 30 días
ayúdenos gracias